I think like the biggest thing that like
annoys me in like the whole dating world
is like [__] talking stages like that
shit's so annoying like the whole like
like and just like the inconsistency in
them dumb hot
oh stop beautiful she's beautiful like
hate that like so much but I think
that's like my biggest thing it's just
like what what specifically just like
the fact of just like you like oh my God
I couldn't listen to the likes word this
like in like talking stages and it's
just like you're like labeled that and
it's like people like she's obviously
nervous it's a filler word the way
people when they speak a lot of times
you'll see you'll hear a lot of um um um
you'll hear a like you'll hear um
there are other little filler words that
I can't even think of I'm guilty of like
sometimes so are you it happens like
this is just Overkill though this is
just like really like Overkill like
totally
so when I was in the the ninth grade we
had this teacher and she took the word
like and put it in a box a shoe box and
like buried it with flowers and all the
stuff and we had a funeral procession
for the word like and this is in the 90s
so this was this is how long this word
has been this is stop being an ass this
is how long this word has been hurting
the English language and she took us out
into the school it's been like that long
and
stop saying it and took us out into the
schoolyard and dug a hole and buried the
box with the word like in it and if she
really made a point I still remember it
to this day and then when I get nervous
sometimes I'm still saying like it's
such a disgusting part of our language
and one of the ways that we've destroyed
it and this girl is the epitome of it
the poor thing God she's gone so viral
for this clip I feel bad for these girls
it is funny oh she'll probably never
speak in public again or at least for a
long time yeah I'm sure she'll she'll
never say like again I hope so or
considered like you can't like you're
just like confused and like most of the
time like the girl get but gets like
attached or something and they like see
it like it's going to lead to a
relationship and it's always not and
it's just like
that's like my biggest thing is like I
just hate the whole like how like
talking stages are so like normalized
like traditional dating does not exist
in this generation
Ben Shapiro reacted to this and I so
often love his take and one other thing
he said is those those initial talking
stages are so weird because when he was
out looking you know dating he was
looking for a wife he was looking for
someone to build a life mother stock
mother stock wanted to build a life with
somebody who had all the qualities he
was looking for and all the qualities he
deserved us the person he was and so
when they went out and they were having
conversations they were around that she
was there for that too and now the
initial conversations are really just
like let me see how fast I can get in
this girl's pants there is zero respect
no real goal to build a relationship and
get to know each other so it's strange
and it is awkward and I'm glad she said
it I wish she said it with more
eloquence but had she said it with more
eloquence nobody would it wouldn't have
gone viral talking stages I haven't had
a talking stage in a while I just don't
do that [__] but if I am talking to a
girl and she is talking to other guys
that is disgusting if she's only talking
and getting to know people that's one
thing no but I'm saying like I agree
where um well maybe this isn't this in
the next it's okay to date and find the
right partner and but if you're talking
and you're talking dirty to multiple
guys and you're fooling around with
multiple guys and the same for guys too
I mean then then
it's all pointless it is it really has
changed my mind on that stuff no he
really has it's not the same it's not
the same for the guys to go talking
about multiple girls and the girl I know
I'm gonna I'm a big misogynist for this
I don't think you're a misogynist for it
I just think you're you're stupid and I
think that you think you think that
talking to multiple girls makes you you
know I don't think it makes you the man
I don't think so no I don't think that
it makes you the man but I think it's
it's totally different like if I'm
talking to a girl and she knows that I'm
talking to multiple girls I don't think
it's as big of a deal but as a guy if
she's talking to multiple guys it's like
it's repulsive like if I'm at the bar or
something or if I'm out with a girl and
I even see her like talking to other
guys it's like right go have them like
like go go like he's yours now I I just
it's just repulsive to me I don't know
maybe I just overthink it but that's
just the truth I also think it's
repulsive if I'm talking to a guy and
he's really laying it on and like making
it seem like we're connecting and then I
find out he's talking to other people
I'm like keep moving same exact reaction
so it's not a guy girl thing you you you
think it is because you're a little
brain I know it is because when I'm out
yeah I was oh because like I'll be out
with girls and I'll be talking to other
girls and then the girl just wants my
attention more you're talking about
people you just met in a bar no I'm
talking about like I go out with girls
I'm just saying it's I agree with them
there I'm not gonna lie all right and
I'm not the biggest like I got a ways to
learn with girls so I'm not that's why I
don't like to talk about it way too much
all right that's the smartest thing
you've said tonight so oh well
to be loyal to you before on the first
date that is probably the most
attractive thing the girl could do but
it's not really saying I'm not seeing
other guys right now I'm girls even know
guys care about that because they'll
pretend innocence even if they're not
that's like a thing girls do when
they're talking to guys is that they'll
pretend they're as innocent as possible
because they know that's what the guy is
into as a guy you don't have to do that
you don't have to pretend and you don't
have to play innocent the girls want you
to be a bit of a player because then
they know you have access and that
you're picking them I totally agree with
that is that not facts even the biggest
hoes they'll pretend like they're not
hoes because they know that that's
disgusting to you and a guy doesn't have
to do that to get the girls do you see
what I'm saying yeah so no I do see what
you're saying that girls pretend to be
more innocent than they are and it you
shouldn't be telling somebody that's
calling you for a date like it's not
about if I can fit you in no that's not
what you're saying I know I'm not like
I'm clearly speaking in hyperbole okay
don't be a an anti-trumper here every
time he said something in her hyperbole
they cried in the streets but when it
when a guy a guy saying oh I'd love to
take you out you know but basically like
if I can fit you into my schedule with
all my other girls that's not what I'm
saying I am speaking in hyperbole that
is not attractive I know you think it
you you think it makes girls like oh I'm
not flip out girls because now you're
just saying stuff that I didn't even say
well what did you say Clarita I'm saying
like if I'm hanging out with a girl or I
meet a girl they don't they pretend or
they they put up the facade or even they
are of Innocence as much as possible
where they're like not if they're truly
into you and you're out with them or
something they're not going to be
talking to other people none of that
[__] and they're not talking to any
other guys or none of that but as a guy
you don't have to pretend and fake
innocence like you're just like some
pure little being like that's not it's
different like I I don't know you're
thinking of Hyperbole and I can't think
of specific examples but I've seen this
countless times going out where they
just want I don't know maybe I'm just
butchering it maybe no maybe I'm just
maybe I just can't understand the
generation maybe I'm just a boomer and
that's all I'm just a boomer yeah let's
just move on just talking to you that is
probably the most attractive thing a
girl could do
say I can guarantee you that on a third
but I mean on the first day but it's
like girls can have all these
requirements and standards and we're
just saying he's just saying as a guy
that's the most attractive thing you can
do so if you want to be more attractive
to the guy then that's what you do as a
guy if I want to be more attractive to
you I have to get my money up I have to
go to the gym I have to build
connections I have to be more
charismatic as a girl you don't have to
do all that [__] guys what you were
saying before before you was saying a
guy can is more attractive if he has a
bunch of girls in play
what what does that have to do with what
I just said because now you're saying
what a guy has to do to be all a girl
has to do is play innocent like you're
the only guy beautiful guy has to do
what guys care about is beauty innocence
and Purity yeah right and I agree with
that okay and then yeah as a guy like
well if you have like a bunch of money
like you were saying if a girl says
she's you talking to another girl it
makes her want you more I didn't
contradict that how did I contradict
that you just gave totally different
reasons though because there's different
reasons it's not like
[Music]
do you believe in gender equality uh
yeah course okay so how do you reconcile
believing in gender equality but also
holding men to their traditional gender
roles of paying for the first date
I'm just saying that's my personal view
a woman can being a feminist is just
doing whatever you want to do
being a feminist is just doing whatever
you want to do I know what she means by
that she sounds like a ding dong but I
know what she means what does she mean
making your own choices and not being
bashed by Society for that and uh
obviously bashing you okay I'm about to
bash you but besides me bashing you for
being stupid it's not and it no one is
bashing you just for being a woman if
women were being bashed just for being
women why would so many men want to
become women why would you do that I
would never why would you take a step
down why would Dylan Mulvaney get all
get surgery to take a step down it's
born inside of you it's not a choice
it's it's just so I'm just very tired of
this young these young girls who have
been so convinced that they are victims
and they're suffering look at her she's
on a hugely famous podcast in a
beautiful city with a lot of stuff that
she paid for hair and makeup and and
boobies and clothes and oh those are
real they are I didn't mean it like that
I I realized that as it came out of my
mouth that it said that way but just
again you have every opportunity in the
world and you want to spend your time
showing off your new manicure on a
podcast instead of going out and
building something of your own and then
say that Society is bashing you and
holding you down that's because this is
how you spend in your time it's not
Society it's you Society it's you so
yeah there's some bashing take it like
um standing up for like women's like
rights and stuff like that but when it I
don't know this question really dense my
question is if you believe in gender
equality don't you think you ought to
split the bill on the first date
um no because my main concern with
gender equality is through like yes in
society like fixing that and through
like the system but yeah what oh my this
poor girl I feel bad I feel bad I'm
sorry I bashed you because you're just a
dingling and I shouldn't be nicer to
ding-a-lings she's just a nice little
sweet little dog that was rough all
right thank you so much for watching
make sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram and join my Discord I'll see
you later come on don't be a jerk say it
say it no follow Sunny's mother on
Twitter and because I want to talk to
you there okay
[Music]
cracking up
enough
[Music]